de présentation vous avez toute une
pente à remonter quand même parce que le
blason il a perdu beaucoup de sa dorure
avec le scandale des initiations c'est
un bon défi mais ça fait partie je pense
que c'est une crise qu'il faut traverser
je pense qu'on va prendre les moyens
pour faire ça aussi je pense que la
volonté du comité exécutif la volonté
des 18 équipes
tout le monde est uni vers une direction
qui qui va en ce sens-là de prendre les
mesures pour s'assurer qu'effectivement
on retrouve cette dorure là est-ce que
est-ce que déterminer le scandale où on
va apprendre d'autres choses est-ce que
ça existe encore j'étais pas dans le
passé il faut toujours être prudent
lorsqu'on dit on pense que tout est
sorti je suis content moi de ce que
Monsieur Courtot a dit en commission la
semaine dernière en disant faut que la
parole se libère si ça vient pas sur le
bureau tu commissaire ou du président du
club c'est dur d'agir alors à partir de
ce moment-là je pense que maintenant si
ces invitations là mais on va voir on
sait qu'au Québec la plupart des équipes
ceux à qui j'ai pas parlé à tout le
monde la date de façon individuelle mais
plusieurs m'ont déjà dit ça se passe pas
chez nous des joueurs qui ont joué dans
les 10-15 dernières années qui ont été
surpris d'apprendre ça donc c'est quand
même une belle confirmation que si c'est
arrivé c'est exceptionnel la parole peut
se libérer pour les gens qui étaient là
dans le passé mais pour les gens qui
sont là actuellement ils sont jeunes
dans la Ligue 1
on est bien mal pris à cet âge-là parce
qu'on nous a tout expliqué en espèce de
loi du silence on va bien paraître on va
pas se faire
de l'équipe aussi puis pour l'instant
les plaintes elles sont traitées à
l'interne et ça c'était reconnu comme
étant un problème qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire avec ça d'abord on a déjà
dit qu'on est très d'accord avec un
processus indépendant ça me permet de
dire en 30 secondes parce que la Ligue
je pense on fait ça de très bonnes foi
la personne allaiter qui s'occupe de ça
a fait un très bon travail mais
maintenant peut-être que c'est
simplement un changement de structure
donc quand on a un problème structurel
mais ça prend une solution qui est
structurée aussi enfin qu'à partir de ce
moment-là on est d'accord avec elle est
dans un processus totalement indépendant
ça c'est déjà décidé même à Jason avec
Dan mais kendji ce matin le commissaire
d'aller canadienne de hockey sont à la
même place maintenant qui et comment ça
ça va être à déterminer mais le
processus va être indépendant de notre
bureau et pour ce qui est des bagarres
les bagarres c'est déjà décidé c'est
déjà arrêté je ne rencontre j'ai été
invitée par la ministre Charest avant la
fin du mois de mars
là on est aussi dans comment
l'implication du règlement pour
peut-être la portion ou un joint qui se
ferait agresser qui essaie de se
défendre qui peut-être qui donne une
pointe un moment donné après 8 secondes
si l'arbitre a pu le temps de intervenir
est-ce que lui doit sortir ou non c'est
pas traitée comme un agresseur en même
temps est clair sur ce qu'on va aller
s'asseoir ensemble on va voir on va
s'expliquer moi je suis très content je
vais pouvoir la rencontrer de la
première fois dans ce rôle là et on va
voir où ça mène je m'attends une belle
conversation
échange de point de vue je vais être à
l'écoute et le but c'est d'avoir une
situation une réglementation qui va
plaire à tous les côtés vous arrivez du
monde des Alouettes
vous êtes encore là c'est ça qui est
incroyable quand même vous êtes vraiment
dans une transition et vous êtes encore
lié aux alouettes
puis la raison pour que tout ça arrive
c'est que la nouvelle de mon arrivée a
coulé presque deux semaines maintenant
alors on a choisi de la confirmer puis
là effectivement j'étais dans la
transaction Hollywood la semaine passée
[Musique]
le rôle de commissaire vous me
corrigerez si je me trompe il y a
commencé en 1919 avec un scandale obèse
bar alors que le con comme le
commissaire ou le président du conseil
d'administration il y avait un équipe
aussi
alors donc ça marche pas quand il arrive
un litige c'est là que les propriétaires
se sont dit dans une crédibilité on va
nommer une personne indépendante
justement par contre c'est sûr que on
travaille en commun pour pour que la
Ligue grandisse on travaille en commun
pour les revenus augmentent on travaille
en commun pour les politiques mais comme
ça c'est l'intégrité alors faut
s'assurer que tout ce qui est
disciplinaire tout ce qui est
réglementation est très suivie et ça les
propriétaires
sont très très très d'accord avec ça
parce que c'est l'encrédibilité à eux
aussi comme les tout le monde veut avoir
une équipe forte mais dans une ligue
forte
un peu les yeux quand on est
propriétaire ben oui il y a des bagarres
mais il y a des gens dans les gradins
qui aime ça fait sortir les foules non
mais ça c'est moins vrai honnêtement il
y a plus de statistiques qui démontent
au Québec je peux pas parler pour
partout au Québec et dans les méritimes
que ça fait vendre on disait ça avant
alors qu'il fait avant qu'on voulait
vendre aux Américains beaucoup de cette
façon-là on est plus il y a tellement de
talent il y a tellement aujourd'hui de
créativité avec le jeu aussi les joueurs
le jeu a tellement évolué on a vraiment
plus besoin il est temps de passer à
autre chose et puis comment vous voyez
ça maintenant l'achat des Alouettes par
Pierre perado
et en fait une bonne nouvelle parce que
on voulait un propriétaire la Ligue
avait énoncé puis quand je suis revenu
c'était pour aider à ce sens-là d'avoir
un acheteur un propriétaire local comme
on dit c'était la seule équipe les
Alouettes dans le propriétaire résidait
pas dans sa ville alors je pense que là
monsieur pelleadour fait ça aussi au
niveau personnel donc ça c'est aussi un
espèce d'engagement c'est toujours bon
quand le propriétaire c'est à dire aux
dépanneur la fin de semaine avec ton
club hier il prend pas plus de fierté la
proximité
bonne transition alors on comprend vous
êtes encore avec les Alouettes à partir
de quand avec la Ligue de hockey 8 mai
bonne chance dans vos nouveaux défis
merci beaucoup au plaisir de vous revoir
merci